you can't get caught up in the game that
most 9 to 11 year old entrepreneurs are
getting caught up in that I talked to
alright you don't see what I'm doing I'm
musically yeah that was funny right my
life's funny
[Music]
over there need a girl I've been working
on this startup myself and I've despite
everyone being really nice I've always
noticed that there's sort of like you're
a bit too young to do this yes how do
you get past the stereotypes or
limitations I think you know the answer
Hillary I think it's in your own head
right like the bottom line is do you
agree with them great you're on your
[ __ ] way right like she like like
listen I is your mom Eater like
leadership like you know like like
you're ready you've already won right
like your question - do you want to hear
something interesting like I don't think
you even believe in the question that
you just asked me and that is the
ultimate compliment because spending
time with you backstage yesterday like I
think that's a cute question but I
actually don't think you give a [ __ ] do
you give a [ __ ] of what people think
right I respect that
I'm I'm I'm gonna tell you something
really right yeah so I'm gonna tell you
something super exciting when I was 12 I
occasionally cared what people thought
too that [ __ ] goes away real quick
that's the answer I'm so what like what
your teacher or your uncle Rick [ __ ]
thinks that you should you're too early
like it's just not gonna matter at the
end Hillary here's what's gonna happen
either you're right or they're right
that's what's gonna happen at the end
spending any time debating who's
cheering for what outcome or what point
of view is a complete waste of your
energy hi I'm Bianca Rochelle from
California California San Francisco how
old are you I'm nine it's so nice to
meet you I'm I'm a rapper and a business
owner I come to events like complex con
I come to neck network because I push
myself and create partnerships with the
with the brands do you think I'm going
at it the wrong way you are definitely
not going about it the wrong way little
one you might be going about it the best
[ __ ] way here are you enjoying it
yeah you love it yeah what do you do
when you grow up um well I'm a rapper so
I really I really um I dream about going
on tours yep like everybody here like
they're coming to see you I want them to
be like that to me I love that listen
can I give you can I give you a real
real real good piece of advice that's
gonna be really hard for you to take but
please remember it and hopefully when we
chop up this video we'll send it to you
mm-hmm
the number one thing you have is time
you have something in here that all of
us envy which is an extra 30 years an
extra 20 years an extra 15 years do you
understand yeah you can't get caught up
in the game that most 9 to 11 year old
entrepreneurs are getting caught up in
that I talked to
all right you don't see what I'm doing
I'm musically listen to me that was
funny right my life's funny listen
listen to me the thing that a lot of you
know single digit entrepreneurs again
and caught up with is you care too much
about how many subscribers and followers
you got if you promise me this it will
help you so much if you just make the
songs that are in your heart if you just
make the content you want if I could get
you to just never look at how many
followers you have for the next 10 years
you will win it's gonna be hard all your
friends are gonna ask how many you know
everybody here cares how many and
they're grown but if you can get to that
place where you don't care about that
one thing it will help you so much you
could never imagine okay can I tell you
something else
yeah if you talk about your real life
which is obviously very different than
our real life based on how you see
things in the world it will be really
interesting [ __ ] yeah that's how my
songs are like I don't tell fake stuff I
really I don't want to tell fake stuff I
want to tell my life story and how I got
here I love it keep getting your thing
girl I love you hey Gary
hey Brooke how's your day been they're
really good CJ how are you good okay so
I just turned 13 and I was wondering
like or I've been doing YouTube for
about two years yeah and the first year
I didn't really get anything done okay
up until this yet anything done as it
didn't get traction or you were
bullshitting playing video games second
both of them
so but then this summer I start to get
more like I quit video games and I got a
better view time and attraction yep but
I'm still like I'm at 142 right now so
I'm wondering like what's one tip you
have for kids my age
142 meaning what 142 subs got it so what
do you want to happen CJ I just want to
get at least 300 by the end of the year
okay well first of all we'll take care
of that right so like now what just to
inspire people good so if you want to
inspire people if that's real right if
that's really what you're about then you
don't need to do anything but continue
to put out the content that you think
will do that thank you I think the
reason I said like we'll take care of
that is what I don't want you to do that
so many people do whether they're 13 or
81 so many people get into the rat race
of how many followers they have right
and like that's just not the game that
you want to play do you know what I mean
because the reality is is that that's
gonna dictate too many actions you can't
let your self esteem or self-worth be
wrapped up into metrics on YouTube
because it's one tiny proxy and the
reality of what you're up to you
understand thank you you're welcome
yeah we're gonna we're gonna throw a
right hook right now what's the name of
your channel CJ CJ bowling spell it
CJ pol ing slower because you want them
to actually [ __ ] follow you CJ
bol ing bol ing it would really mean a
whole lot to me if I've given you one
inch of value ever in my life for you to
follow this kid let's let's see how many
followers he has on YouTube by the end
of this weekend yeah
get in your seat yes and my mom I don't
even know that I don't even know that
we're not fresh I was right Oh Ashley
I'm so glad we got to meet my man you
like the content what are you gonna do
when you rock my man all right what are
you gonna talk about you'll figure it
out what are you making some content now
yeah what you talked about your life
your interests the stuff you're into
what are you into mm-hmm I'm glad we met
man want to take a photo let's do it
all right can you do me a favor don't
ever ever ever ever worry about how many
people are subscribed to your channel
the number one reason kids lose on
YouTube is they care too much about how
many people are subscribed to them just
be patient make sure content nobody was
following me for a long long time longer
than you were alive right now
got it do you understand you promise
[Music]
[Music]